top of the lineup in jose siri he's off
to a good start in his young career nine
for 20.
three home runs and 20 at bats
as he crushes one you kidding me to left
field where is this one gonna end up in
the home bullpen the second bullpen in
left beyond the astros pen
jose siri
starts this road trip off with a bang
there's a lot of people around houston
saying hey siri right now one nothing
astros
one out no one on for jordan alvarez
and he hits one hard to right field and
that is over the head of jose rojas off
the wall hit it so hard that he has to
hold up with a single
that was a bullet to right
yulie inside out swing into center field
that'll be down for a hit
the cuban connection of jordan alvarez
and julie guriel back-to-back singles
here
in the first sitting the astros with
three hits of their first four hitters
correa coming in batting 280
up the middle that's a base hit jordan
alvarez around third he'll score carlos
correa rbi number 86 on the air makes it
a two-nothing astros lead the astros out
to an early lead for their left-handed
pitcher who's on the bound tonight from
valdez will be making his 20th
appearance he is 10-5 with a 3-2-6
109 strikeouts on the season
wow proper valdez just pouring him into
the strike zone and brandon marsh didn't
offer any of the three
he'll go down on strikes to start this
one
on the ground
marwyn gonzalez to his right makes the
play
3-2 on the ground julie guriel will take
it to the bag himself
and a good first inning for fraumer
valdez a one two three start
got him
first time ever frommer has struck out
jared walsh as he wins this battle
got ahead
pitch on the way swing and a miss got
him on the curve ball ring hifo down on
three pitches and the ending is over
probably able to strand a couple
off the glove of berea
fletcher is not going to have a chance
to make the play uli hit it hard
deflected by the pitcher and yulia's two
for two
line drive base in right field carlos
correa matches yuli guriel both are two
for two tonight
as they are on base here with two outs
maria another o2
pounces on
it and gets out of the inning
on the ground to correa under hands it
to marwyn for one sidearm throw for the
double play correa to gonzalez to curiel
and that's how this inning will end
robert valdez gets a double play
kyle tucker sends one deep to right
field that'll be down for a hit and one
hop over the wall
maybe a bad break for the astros if that
ball stayed into play yuli could have
potentially scored instead it'll be
second and third with two outs
another one two
lined in the left gosling coming gosling
there
leave two still two nothing
oh give it to him yes sir from valdez
picks up a strikeout on the hook
getting jose rojas looking beautiful
curveballs in that sequence
mayfield hits the ball high and deep to
center field all the way back mccormick
and alvarez
thankfully they did not collide because
chaz would not have done well in that
collision
but jordan pulled up at the last moment
3-2
got him
big strikeout for from valdez getting
shohei ohtani for out number two
frauber knew what he was throwing
martine maldonado knew what he was
throwing shohei ohtani knew what he was
throwing and still couldn't get to it
great reaction from fraumer valdez who
reached back and made a pitch when he
needed it
[Music]
ground ball right side mario gonzalez
makes the play and that'll do it proper
valdez strands a couple of runners in
the sixth inning of hitting a one from
her down in a crouch
knowing the importance of this next
pitch
[Applause]
line drive backhanded by correa the
bounce throw to first in time
and the astro strand the base is loaded
a bullet to the backhand of correa who
makes the play
for the final out of the inning
wow marwan gonzalez over three couple of
ground outs and a flyout
barwin with a base hit into right field
in between first and second around third
comes carlos correa he'll score
borrowing gonzalez a big rbi makes it a
three-nothing game here in the eighth
there's martin maldonado hit the ball
hard a couple of times tonight
martine hits one to center field deep
all the way back marsha the walk on
martine maldonado hits with a straight
away center field towards the rocks for
a three run shot and the astros have
broken it open it is now a six to
nothing game
little tapper carlos hustling that's a
four hit night for carlos correa
correa matches his career high with a
four hit knife to start this road trip
now the bases are filled
as marwin gonzalez will back
[Music]
that ball crushed
deep to right field that's a grand slam
marwyn gonzalez
hits a 1-0 pitch out to right for a
grand slam to give the astros a 10 spot
tonight the eighth four runs now in the
ninth inning
well blubber it's ten nothing as we head
to the bottom half of the ninth inning
and a guy just activated today will get
a chance to make his major league debut
and here he is seth martinez
got in on the hands and
fly ball to right field jose siri hasn't
been very busy tonight and right that
slider has become more of a sweeping
slider and that's been a key pitch for
him gets a ground ball here could end
the game four six three game over
astros win the opening game on this road
trip ten to nothing
in the process they reduce their magic
number down to six with the oakland a's
losing at home to seattle
plummer that's a great way to kick off
the west coast swing